This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
6 Minute English
from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello and welcome to 6 Minute English, I'm Sophie.
And I'm Neil. So, Sophie, I watched Snow White and the Huntsman on TV last night.
Oh, you mean the modern retelling of the story Snow White?
Did you enjoy it, Neil?
Uh, it was okay, but the seven dwarves were no fun.
I prefer the original Disney cartoon version.
Don't be silly, Neil. What Disney didn't invent the story?
The movie you watched is a remake, a film that has been made again.
But the fairy tale is very old.
Well, that may be true, but I still prefer the Disney version with funny dwarves.
In the new version, even the names of the dwarves are different and, you know,
serious looking.
But this new version is for young adults.
It's a different genre or style of film.
Names like Sneezie, Dopey, Happy and Grumpy are two childish.
Hmm, what's wrong with childish?
Oh, it's right up your street, isn't it, Neil?
It's too right.
Anyway, fairy tales are the subject of today's show,
and I have a question for you.
Which movie star played the role of the evil fairy in Maleficent?
A 2014 film based on the fairy tale Sleeping Beauty.
Was it A, Kate Blanchett, B, Angelina Jolie, or C, Mell Striep?
Well, I'll go for A, Kate Blanchett.
She often plays evil characters.
I can't forget her in the 2008 movie, Indiana Jones,
in the Kingdom of the Crystal Skull.
Ha, well, we'll find out if you chose the right movie star later on in the program.
But, to return to the idea of childish fairy stories,
let's listen to Diane Perkis, a children's author.
Talking about how originally, fairy tales were intended for an adult audience.
Interestingly, there has been a bit of a move towards seeing fairy tales as an adult,
or at any rate, a young adult, a dark sort of genre.
And that's natural because actually in the past,
fairy tales were told by adults to adults and William Shakespeare's time.
It's only in the Victorian era that they become moral children's tales,
and it looks like we're going back to the inception of fairy stories now with a more adult take on them.
Diane Perkis, so these Hollywood remakes aimed at the teen market, are actually returning fairy tales
to an adult audience. That's right, Neil. And dark here means scary or frightening.
The Victorians toned down this dark content, or made it less forceful.
They also introduced a moral or message about what's right and wrong to the tales.
And inception means the beginning. So, fairy tales began as a dark genre.
Can you give us some examples of dark stories written by the Brothers Grim, Neil?
Well, I have a list here. Let's see, in the frog prints, the print says,
doesn't kiss the frog. She throws it. She throws it against the wall.
Yes. I prefer the kiss version.
And in Little Red Riding Hood, don't believe that version where the wolf
shuts granny in a cupboard in the real version. She gobbles her up and then eats red riding hood for
dessert. Charming. And to gobble something up means to eat it very fast.
Oh, okay, that's enough. Let's move on. Did you know that some of the stories,
like Beauty in the Beast, Red Riding Hood, Cinderella and Snow White,
go back much further than the earliest written stories? Even the ones in Latin and Greek?
No, I didn't. And to be honest, Sophie, I thought, I thought, well, Disney had written them.
Oh, Neil. Well, research suggests that some fairy tales date back to well before the Brothers Grim,
and even Shakespeare. Let's hear more from Dr. Jamie Tarani, anthropologist at Durham University
in the UK. So these fairy tales we've looked at, we've been able to trace back really thousands
of years, probably sort of four to six thousand years is the origin of many famous European
folk tales stories such as Beauty in the Beast. At six thousand years.
Yep, going right back to the Bronze Age. We've been able to trace the transmission across
generations of these stories much further back than is generally recognised.
But Sophie, if there's no written evidence of the stories from six thousand years ago,
how does Dr. Tarani, who we've just heard from, know people, we're telling them?
Well, dating languages isn't something I'm familiar with. I think it's a bit like looking at
a few dinosaur bones and trying to reconstruct what dinosaurs looked like. But here, you're trying
to reconstruct stories without any actual bits. It must have been hard work for the researchers.
Indeed. Well, I think it's time to hear the quiz question again, Sophie.
Okay, I asked which movie star played the role of the evil fairy in Maleficent,
a film based on the fairy tale Sleeping Beauty? Was it A, Kate Blanchett, B, Angelina Jolie,
or C, Mel Streep? I said Kate Blanchett. And you were wrong. Angelina Jolie played the main character
in the film Maleficent. Kate Blanchett played the Elf Queen Galadriel in Lord of the Rings,
and Mel Streep played a blue-haired witch in the 2014 film Into the Woods.
Now, can we hear those words again? Okay, remake, genre, dark, toned down, moral,
inception, gobble up. Well, that's the end of today's Spellbinding
6 Minute English. Don't forget to join us again soon. Goodbye. Bye-bye.